so I've seen both you guys fight with
people on Twitter both of you do it more
than me I've done it a couple times and
we've talked about a night light all
right so all right so I'll start with
you so when you fight with these people
on Twitter and I see the way you do it
and it usually starts respectfully right
I've never seen you just like launch
into a unscathed
you know you know relentless unwarranted
attack it usually starts somewhat
respectively and then it degrades
because they don't act in a way that
would allow for normal debate now we
could oh that could also be the twitter
is just not the place to have a real
debate of ideas and all that but within
the confines of Twitter well I think I
remain always respectful I might become
a bit more forceful so maybe I'll take
an example of the the great
sarcastically Bill Nye right right where
he was able to link all of the Terrorism
around the world to the lack of solar
panels climate change and carbon
emissions yeah when I hear a buffoon
utter such a thing when he has access to
millions of people it offends me to the
deepest of my soul yeah therefore I come
after you not because I mean I never
swear I never insult him personally but
I am going to be relentless in
advertising your astonishing stupidity
so in a case like that
and I don't know exactly what Bill Nye
said but solar panels causes terrorism
yeah that was it that was it all right
so in a case like that so what I see
these guys do often is there's a kernel
of truth in what they're saying so in
his case my guess is what he was saying
is that because there's been a bad
drought in Nigeria that thus has led to
more sectarian violence because they're
fighting over dwindling resources about
like there's some kernel of truth there
there's also curbs their oxygen also was
there yeah so oxygen was a multiplier
effect right precisely and also I'm
pretty sure that just because you didn't
have the right resources doesn't mean
you'd automatically be throwing gas off
roofs there's getting that link but so
they start with the kernel and then it
just like goes ooh this is there's a I
think it depends on what your objective
is when you go into Twitter and you have
these conversations I tried to get into
the mentality that if I
dress a person who's attacking me or
trying to give an argument against me on
Twitter I try make it more for the
people who are following me then that
person because very unlikely I'm going
to come into that person of the other
thing but I can at least give tools to
the person to the people follow me to
how to address that argument for example
a lot of people who if I will talk about
the Quran will come out you with very
specific arguments one of the things
they'll say well you don't speak Arabic
therefore you don't understand the Quran
or you get with it therefore you fry it
that you do but how does that help the
followers who don't send ratted and so
you could say like if Arabic cannot be
translated to English English English
then cannot be translated to Arabic so
how can you read Arabic or I could ask
them if I'm not a Muslim because I can't
read the Quran in Arabic what about you
know uh almost 50% of Pakistan which is
illiterate who can't read a word of any
language are they Muslim or not how
about a share of Malaysia or Indonesia
and Malaysia so and that then they get
very confused and then they start
getting desperate and calling you names
and that's what that's where they lose
and that's where you can disengage
because the conversation is pretty much
over
and when my followers see that now they
have a tool now they can say I have this
argument against you which is just a
fallacy right it's a total fallacy well
that's why I sort of have a love/hate
relationship with sort of the discussion
online why I like this actually a lot
more because a you have this huge amount
of people that are anonymous and that
you know their cartoon avatars and I'm
sure I'm sure most of them are perfectly
nice people and they're always saying
nice things about me right the people
that like me so like I I'm not saying
anything about them specifically but the
value of the interactions I think has
has been degraded significantly over the
last couple months I sense that there's
something going on in general in the
world of social media and then when you
hear that you know Facebook is banning
at ex-muslim groups and all this that
it's a calm it's like a conflation or a
combination of it's coming from the
people that their value the value of
their words doesn't mean as much anymore
and it's coming from the social anomie
organizations that's a lot it's a big
thing I've noticed another thing people
love you until you say take a position
that is contrary to something that is
very holy to them so outside
aslam analyst yeah it could be as simple
as I love Messi and Ronaldo is nothing
compared to Messi that's far more
controversially I will get people who
will start insulting me to the point
where I have to block them yeah because
they are strong Renato support right I
am against trophy hunting so somebody
says you know I thought you were the
sharpest loveliest most accomplished guy
until you said that stupidity
you're an [ __ ] you're a pig you're a
Nazi so there is this mindset where
unless you agree with a person a public
figure on a hundred percent of issues
yeah they will find that one issue and
suddenly you become vilified in ways
that are truly breathtaking right and so
what's interesting about that is you're
saying that about the people on that are
mostly on our side
so that's why we that's why the policing
the self policing why I always say I'm
on the left that's why I got a police
lab that's why it's so important so it's
a different policing now you know we're
we're in the macro sense we're always
policing the left-right of progress
either progressives and and yet we have
to now police sort of even within our
group the people that are that are
pushing us forward we have to police
them on some language stuff I got a I
got a decent sound if that sounds very
Authority what it is yeah please
someone's going to edit that badly I got
a I made a comment on an article from
salon that said a richer New Atheists
have to become new vegans mmm bye Steve
stank officious the guy in Australia and
I tweeted really great writer and I and
I tweeted out and I say you know salon
you're drunk go home yeah and so Steve
so first I you sent out that tweet and
my subgroup of my followers go ballistic
on me
police me just like you're saying I had
to block a couple because they just quit
animalistic on me but these were people
who followed me who were kind of fans of
mine and but the difference is is that
Steve contacted me said you know I saw
your comment and he said actually salon
changed my title and I began dialoguing
with him and I tweeted out that he that
he had been kind of you know manipulated
his article I still had issues with a
lot of his opinions in his article so we
talked a while and I said would you like
to talk to me on video on my podcast and
I'll pronounce it
- and we became very close friends since
then even though we still disagree I'm
not even close to being a big as a
Chilean I meet all okay I'm sure that's
why I but there's a difference between
the attack you know in policing a person
is a different opinion and just saying
oh that's interesting let's talk about
it and isn't that funny that to me is a
religious concept that you need purity
and thought to really appreciate someone
that's the way religious people why
example that shouldn't be coming out of
left and that's gonna so that's why this
whole thing about ideas and connecting
with people like I'm sure if we you know
I know that the three of us agree on
most things probably like if we really
were just not on everything note are
worse so he spit Star Trek's better than
Star Wars really high on my land and
Chile beat Argentina in the final of
Copa America so he's my enemy so so you
guys are enemies I mean were enemies we
got to figure out something that but
that's the point it doesn't even matter
and I'm sure we could sit here long
enough I have really no idea what you
guys think about economics I'm sure we
could find things that we disagree and
it would be it would be irrelevant to us
being friends or being public people
together or whatever but that's
different than what I think we've seen a
lot of these guys do on the regressive
side advice that they don't they're the
rules of debate are completely gone with
them which is why you'll find out that
they're plagiarists mmm often or you'll
find out that they you blatantly lie
about people's they lie about their own
history academic history or they lie
about other people's words now I am NOT
a perfect person by any measure and have
you know done all kinds of things about
but you won't find me manipulating other
people's ideas for my own benefit and
that's I think that's a if we're gonna
be in a public space I think that's a
pretty and I think that's the thing
that's what's so galling to Sam Harris
right because he can't understand how
these people could be so dishonest in
the manner in which they soil his
reputation despite the fact that he has
repeatedly tried to deal with some of
those accusations but they're
impenetrable for that reason and and I
think that as you know Isis Sam is
somebody who ultimately cares about
the purity of the process each simply
can't understand why people would be so
duplicitous yeah you know I asked you
this when we set them for our one-on-one
about science I insane to talk about
religion is a crazy thing because we're
you're want people that care about
quantifiable stuff to talk about the
leap of faith and those things have
nothing to do with each other and that's
really why I wanted to get involved in
this conversation because I saw what
they were doing to Sam and I was like
here's a guy that's pretty doing some
decent stuff and if he needs some help
so if I've helped in any way then I then
I've done something good here I think
here's another strategy by the way that
they do and I went after is it a bee or
a bee I don't know I'm Martin I'd be
Martin I had seen her on Joe Rogan
basically arguing that you know Sam
Harris doesn't have the right to speak
about the issues that he speaks about
because you know he's a neuroscientist
and so you know one of the ways that I
tackle stupidity is that I satirize it
to the extreme yeah and so I started
identifying very very famous people you
know Bertrand Russell the philosopher
Isaac Newton and Albert Einstein and
then whenever they uttered something
that was outside the sphere I would
answer with shut up schmuck yeah well
guess what she didn't come after me
because I've satirized her position in
such a way that actually it is
embarrassing - you're such a position
so it's interesting so that's your
methodology right you satirize these
people and you've done it with your ass
last song you were five Dakota 5,000
which basically if you say anything can
you give us an example of this and I
want to talk about that so 9/11 and you
open the thing yeah Jews you know
anything anything Iraq war Iraq war
Israeli occupation yeah Syria at Jews
yeah only has two settings I think is
the point so your method though is is
satirizing right my method is really
discussing these ideas I think your
methods a little different which is you
find what these people say you find the
clip you post the clip and then you're
like this is bull [ __ ] it's swinging to
his to his example of Sam with Abby
Martin Abby Martin goes on Joe Rogan
says why should a journalist you know
talk about politics with the nearest
line
that's ridiculous you know from the
start he has no point no position here
to take at all well she's a great
admirer and has had Noam Chomsky on her
social take that clip you know it's a
very short clip it you know 15 seconds
he just put up up there Abby Martin is a
great fan of Noam Chomsky who is a
linguist right who speaks every day
about international politics yeah so do
you discard him Abby Martin of course
she'll never address that and people see
that and they're like oh of course it's
it's a perfect analogy is a perfect
example it's you discarded right away
well you know my six degrees of noam
chomsky thinking you know that one no I
don't think so
so that basically is it for any single
calamity in the world you have to in six
causal steps or less Lincoln I mean
that's us industrial military complex so
a frog dies in the Amazon go you have to
link it to it well frog dies in the
Amazon now I would assume that America
has some companies somewhere in the
Amazon and we've done some deforestation
right so because of the deforestation
which is causing green harvin emissions
solar panels just solar panels next
thing you know Assad has to bomb
somebody yeah I mean I got that's there
you go yeah yeah so so that's really
interesting because I think that's a
cool spot it shows the difference of
people so we all sort of think the same
things about this stuff but our methods
are different right and I think that's
really a beautiful thing because not
everybody would be as tolerant to sit
for the long-form conversation that I'm
gonna do and not everyone's going to
take the time to do what you do and
really dig into those video it's must be
painful right I've message you sometimes
and I'm like man you got to watch that
[ __ ] again like it's enough you know
it's getting really hard to to get
through them but uh but yeah I mean to
to what he was saying about a Chomsky
and the degrees of a methodology before
you had in the one-on-one you spoke
about Reza Aslan and his you know the
words have no meaning it has no
connection to religion I kind of find it
funny that these people are very
obsessed that the words of Sam Harris
have a negative effect on yeah yeah but
for some reason just religious books
this doesn't count for you know Socrates
or Shakespeare or political theory no no
no for some reason new atheist write a
book
a negative effect on people yeah
religion can't for some reason it is
baffling but that's the thing is what
I've seen in the more that we've engaged
these guys all of them and the ones that
I've engaged ones that you've engaged
that even what they do now is I'll see
them now arguing the same things that
we've been arguing for for months so for
example when the whole thing blew up on
real time and Sam was saying you know
there are there are degrees look at the
polls there are hardcore Islamists there
are nominal Muslims that don't care
about the religion they're you know
showing this and he said it's circles
right he said it's circles of this well
then after trashing him and slandering
him and lying about him for months
Genki ogor then goes on his show and
shows the exact circles except guess
what he used squares yeah that's tough I
did it I did it squares I clicked
comparing these two we're hitting like
30 seconds I showed exactly Sam Harris
talking about jihad ease Islamist
moderates and he said there's concentric
circles he said this to Ben Affleck and
then jank almost a year later after
calling him a bigot for saying exactly
that he called him you know so is that
progress is that about it before we get
to that yeah we were talking earlier
about self-deception yeah so you you
have a window into the mind of Jenk
do you think that he's engaging in
self-deception does he truly believe it
what we honestly don't know I you know
people ask me this all you know it's
funny because I'll talk about a little
bit of my experience there and for the
little bit that I've talked about it
actually people always are asking me so
I don't but for the purposes of us being
here I'll talk about it I mean I
literally have no idea at this point I
don't think you could be that dumb I
don't think he's that dumb I don't think
he's a dumb person so he's just about
the niche and he's milking it I think
it's basically a niche and it's cliques
and Sam's really good for cliques and if
you put that video up that three-hour
interview that they did that they laid
in eight commercials or whatever and
it's a three-hour video eight
commercials with over a million views
it's a lot of money right and you know
there's money in [ __ ] and you know I
think it look I started there so I you
know I don't regret anything because
that's what got me here but the way I
treat this is very different I try not
to do clickbait stuff I try to treat
things the way that I would want do
study basketball together we don't
basketball but I had hurt my knee right
at right Chazz this whole thing was
happening and now I'm in a different
game now but yeah what because he got
but that's the sad thing how you know I
can sit here with the Ben Shapiro who's
far right for me right or Milo who's on
the right or any of these people on the
right I can sit there and have a debate
with them and you know what we at the
end we'd be like all right fine you want
to get a drink and I've had a drink with
Milo and it's like I couldn't have a
drink with those guys at this point why
would I ever want to have a drink with
Reza you know what I mean would you I
mean you know like but how do you feel
about the the format that they had is
that they basically just bring up a
story and it's an echo chamber they
rarely have people on
I think they don't invite people on to
speak not quite honest I think it's a
waste of our mental energy to just focus
on that I think your question though
about the motives is an interesting
thing because motives in general is
interesting I don't I just simply don't
know because I'm not a mind reader but a
lot of them a lot of the regressive seem
to be mind reader's about all of us
right right but I will not profess to be
a mine writer so I don't know but in
terms of that part like everyone can do
whatever the hell they want in this era
it is are there any things that's so far
since you've started this new adventure
that you haven't liked about the
experience I mean I know most of it is
positive but what are some negative
things um it's really been great
actually
from from beet one when I did the test
show with you in August 2 right now I
had no idea this was gonna happen it's
not putting an asterisk sir as a regular
show I don't want an asterisk next to it
a great GAD set on thank you so do
reincarnated Ruben report it's been
great really it's I had never thought
that you know it really feels like my
whole life's culmination like this does
feel like my life's work so that's
extremely rewarding I think on the
negative side yeah I've lost a bunch of
friends okay but we're by no reason for
no reason other than we disagree on some
stuff right but you made new ones then I
made plenty of new ones and I know I
would much rather have you guys than
them so and several of the other people
that I've met too so so I don't regret
it and it doesn't but there so there's
been some cost in that and I would say
that the bigger cost is probably for you
guys too it's just it's a lot it's a lot
to think about this stuff all the time
you know I always I don't worry about my
new things I don't worry about what I'm
having for dinner or little things but I
do worry about
this this is big and I do spend a lot of
time thinking about it and it you know
late at night night thinking you know
I'm thinking about it you know sometimes
my wife will walk into my study and just
by the posture that I have or how I'm
looking she'll literally say all right
what did somebody say because she
literally kicked based on my general the
aura that I'm exuding whether I'm an and
she'll she'll often come and just try to
close the laptop yeah because I am so
engaged yeah but that's what's actually
but that's what's cool about people like
us connecting because you know
forgettable you have taken a load off of
me on this you know you didn't mean that
sounded really quite you you have
lessened some of the burden on me you
know you mean because of this and you
have to in a way and I hope that we've
all done that a little bit for Sam and
some of the other people that are in
this space because the more of us that
wake up it makes it easier for everyone
it's exactly what you the scientific
principle that you were talking about
before yeah exactly
all right well listen we could obviously
talk forever I've asked a bunch of
questions here you've asked me a couple
but I asked you each to bring one
question for the other to solo well I
have a really different question may
I'll start with God side so Star Wars or
Star Trek and why uh here's where I'm
gonna lose a lot of votes geez followers
you can say battle stir
I despise both of them oh all right so
I'm not a science fiction guy so this
this Wars there is a three way this just
became the middle I suspect that I'm
never going to be invited on the show
again
I'm actually canceling dinner today we
had reservations at a great restaurant
it's not happening really so what why
why I the the escapism that is afforded
through this kind of science fiction
doesn't appeal to me I like to see real
stories about real people and so I just
can never connect even when I was a
young kid to the battle stars and the
the flying saucers and I just I don't
like it well you're wrong about that
Dave wait wait they would just let me
hit on that real quick that's funny
because to me it's the complete reverse
I love the escapism all right and that's
why I like Star Wars more than Star Trek
because Star Wars to me is more escapism
because you're talking about the force
and this ephemeral right thing and there
is you know where
our trek is based more on earth actually
and you know there's more of a political
bent to it I start with is plenty of
politics too but that's why I love it I
love the escapism of all that and I love
even the the spiritual part of it which
isn't a huge part of my life here on
earth and there's certainly as a
spiritual part too slow the force but
also the sign I think you'd like the
science of Star Trek you have to watch
an episode who watches the Watchers
where they actually break a gun what is
not the first command the prime
directive where they actually intervene
accidentally with a society on another
planet that's kind of like you know in
the Bronze Age and they one of them
accidentally sees John Luke Picard and
he thinks it's a God and calls him the
Picard and there's a storm he says the
Picard is angry and they don't how do
they address this now they've created
this false God for them do they try and
you know deprogram that front from
society or do they let it flow there's
actually a try but yeah the
anthropological aren't a cargo called
Zack yeah yeah after Fineman wrote a lot
about them there's a it's a religion on
on uh I think it's not not that I forget
the the the specific place but it's
called the cargo cult so you can look it
up and you can you actually know where
their religion came from because it came
from during world war ii cargo planes
that start dropping in car goes down
there and they had no idea what's going
on wow that a first legit religion i
than that yeah that also is very much
like an episode of the simpsons with
Lisa puts her tooth in a thing and a
whole civilization ever watched or some
sense all right I'm losing moving on I'm
finished yeah Wow did you have something
else for me or shuli I have a question
for you yeah han Solo or Spock yeah I
mean come on this is silly this is how I
want to hear what I'm course alright
Europe so I wrote an article in on
Psychology Today maybe about a year and
a few months ago where I asked people to
think about the following exercise if
they could have dinner with any ten
people from history who would they be
and then I offered my choices so then
I'll turn this question to you guys of
course one of yours
be me so down to nine we get back right
so you don't have to do ten but can you
think of a few yeah that would be
indispensable at that party well I guess
this one will sound kinda cliche but I
would say Jesus okay because if you look
he lived forget
the religious part for a second we know
that this historically was an actual
person right so if you so just taking
the life of this person that fought the
Jewish authorities right he wanted to
modernize Judaism it was hated by them
for that then fought the Roman
authorities and that by doing so even if
you even if you don't believe in
religion in any way his life just by
being this rebel you know this flip-flop
wearing rebel sparked something that
unfortunately I think has been very
distorted from anything that he would
have ever wanted it to be but I think to
sit there and be like wow man can you
believe what you did I think that would
be pretty good that's a that's the big
one for me I think
well the selfish answer from you would
be Shakespeare cuz I'm a big fan okay
and I was selfish because I have another
one all explained but that's a selfish
one for me because I'm a big Shakespeare
fan and I would really specifically
asked him why did Iago hate Othello so
one of that's one of my favorite place
III you know I ponder over that all the
time uh the non selfish answer would be
for my father would be Albert Einstein
since I was very young he's been
wrestling with a Einstein's theories and
you know I'm writing his own theories
against Isis he's a physicist so I know
that he would just you know love to have
sit-down with Einstein and just you know
converse and debate those those theories
your loved one or some of mine he's a
good yeah go ahead I mean I won't give
all ten but some of mine are pretty
obvious Charles Darwin Albert Einstein
Isaac Newton and Leonardo da Vinci and
Galileo Galileo because he's sort of the
founder of the scientific method and
Leonardo da Vinci because I respect so
much the fact that he was a polymath I
mean he was a thinker scientists a
painter an artist and I really respect
somebody who can excel in so many
domains well very cool well listen
clearly we could do this for
forever before we wrap this thing up
this would be the right time for me to
announce that you guys are soon to be
part of the aura family I'm very excited
about this we are launching a new
vertical that is going to be all about
free speech and free thought and free
expression and all of the things that we
so deeply care about and you two are the
first two people I'm sort of heading up
the operation and you two of the first
two that I'm bringing on board and you
both accept it immediately thank you and
then we're going to be bringing on some
other YouTube creators and some other
interesting people and it's going to be
you guys creating videos and writing
articles and whatever basically whatever
you want to make of it but a hub for the
things we care about it so I'm very
excited about thank you for the
opportunity
yeah all right cool well I want to thank
these guys I think you know them at this
point got in Lallo
and four more of their anti regressive
ideas follow them on Twitter a CAD sad
at Lalo - gosh and subscribe to their
YouTube channels the link is in the
description right down below and that
new site will be coming probably in
about a week or two we'll keep that
quiet for now thanks for watching we'll
do it again next week